moving on we always love it when we can
say only on cbs mornings especially
when it comes to revealing the latest
selection in oprah's book club her new
pick is called
that my bird has my wings the
autobiography of an innocent man on
death row it's written by jarvis j
masters is his name and more than 20
years ago masters was sentenced to death
by lethal injection for a crime he was
never accused of committing you're me
right never accused of committing our
lead national correspondent david
begnell spoke with oprah about why she
picked this book and then he also
interviewed masters from outside
california's san quentin state prison
the man who's now the centerpiece pick
of oprah's book club lives deep inside
of san quentin california's oldest
prison my name is jauris masters i've
been in san quentin for 35 years this
video of jarvis j masters from 2016
provides a rare look at the place that
holds the largest population of death
row inmates in the country step back
away from the sale please there's no way
to show you more because it's against
california law to bring cameras into
state prisons to interview a specific
prisoner but inmates may call out you
have a prepaid call from the jarvis
masters
an inmate at the california state prison
san quentin hello jarvis good morning
hey is this david how are you doing i am
well how are you feeling this morning
well you know i'm nervous for sure
nervous why
paris because i'm talking to cbs i mean
who does that you know
jarvis masters arrived at san quentin in
1981 from long beach california
and it was there at the age of six he
was first picked up by police because he
had run away
he was abandoned by his mother and
father
tell me about this armed robbery that
you committed
which ones how many were there
there were a bunch of them yeah i got
convicted of maybe 14 15.
wow
i had ran away from the youth authority
i just
needed the money you've written two
books finding freedom that bird has my
wings that bird has my wings is the
reason we are talking today it was
picked for oprah's book club
what was your intention
for writing that book
my intention for writing that book was
to speak to the kids people who were at
risk i saw all those faces in that book
when i wrote it more and more i began
feeling like i was telling their story
as well as mine this call and your
telephone number will be monitored and
recorded and it's interesting over
because when you interview an inmate you
only have about six minutes and then the
phone cuts off and they have to call
back were you you were able to talk to
him and actually hear his voice yeah wow
jarvis masters how did you first hear
the name i was interviewing pima
children the buddhist monk spiritual
teacher pima chodron wrote the
introduction and she suggested that i
read the book and that was i think
around 2014
over eight years ago
i read the book
loved the book wanted to choose the book
as a book club
then
or at least get an interview with him
then
i called the then governor of california
i appealed to the entire prison system
my team called we could not get an
interview jarvis masters now a buddhist
wrote about his journey from a hardened
street kid whose life took an even more
terrible turn
four years into his 20-year armed
robbery sentence
that's when prison guard howl dean
birchfield was killed by inmates in a
single stab wound to the heart
and though jarvis masters was never
accused of committing the murder
he was accused of making the device to
commit the crime i was charged with it i
never understood why i was charged for
it
did you have anything to do with making
the tool the instrument that was used to
kill him
absolutely not
no
the record shows at the 1990 court
sentencing that the judge said quote he
was born into hell he was born for
reasons it is almost impossible for me
to comprehend if people don't want
children they shouldn't have them
apparently his mother didn't know how to
not have them
[Music]
and he's now in his 60s
and that statement still sticks with him
today
wouldn't it stick for somebody saying
not only somebody but somebody who's
sentencing you to death saying you
should have never even been born i said
to him on the call
jarvis what happened to you
wow and his voice changed and he said oh
man
and he took us back to long beach at 12
i was arrested for committing the first
crime and he said i was a young boy when
i walked into the house and i heard that
my latest foster mom and stepdad were
telling the social worker they were
seriously ill and that the boy would
have to leave
and that just
turned my world upside down even before
i got into these other foster homes
i felt betrayed one of the things that
sparked the fire for me he talks about
the thing that carried him through life
was
holding on to the love that people had
shared with him you know in spite of you
know his mother being a heroin addict in
spite of all the
crazy violent things that were happening
in their house and and and that moment
you believe that no matter what my
mother loves me no matter how many times
you've been abandoned it's the love
that carries you through so some people
will hear this and say a death row
inmate oprah's book club what what's the
intention behind the pick
you know that's my favorite word
number one my intention is to expose the
story
number two my intention is to let people
know that there are a lot of people on
death row and a lot of people in prison
for whom there has been a miscarriage of
justice i do not believe
that the crime that he is on death row
for
that he was involved in or committed
oprah winfrey has gone so far as to help
find a team of defense lawyers that is
now led by michael williams an attorney
with kirkland and ellis the world's
largest law firm at the time that jarvis
was convicted the state of california
had in their possession a confession by
another individual saying that he had
committed the crime not jarvis
these are three people critically
involved in the case that's right and it
was their testimony that was used to
convict jarvis masters yes when you have
an innocent man on death row it's not
just one person who said something that
was wrong the people who were now saying
that jarvis didn't do it
are the key crucial characters who were
actually convicted of doing it yes or
pleaded to doing it so the case was
built on the words of these people
exactly and now their words are changing
exactly now their words have long since
changed
the jarvis i'm speaking to now
sounds like a soft reflective man
the jarvis you're telling me about seems
scary and intimidating what changed you
i think what changed me is becoming 23
and now i'm becoming 60
and everything in between that yes
buddhism helped me it really really
exposed the suffering that we all live
inside of
growing up inside the violence
here
knowing what violence does to people
it changed you you had 60 seconds
remaining part of the reason that his
story is so extraordinary is because he
has been living in hell for 40 years you
know people who
are on death row you know people go
crazy they kill themselves they become
really cynical and bitter and angry and
he did the opposite david chef an
award-winning author who wrote the book
the buddhist on death row says he found
evidence that jarvis masters has helped
people while in prison so jarvis
embraced this new path of committing
himself to trying to alleviate suffering
in every way that he could he stopped
at least two people from being stabbed
in the yard you think he's innocent i'm
100 convinced he's innocent i've read it
all
i believe that if he had had real
representation that he never would have
been convicted given all the pain you
endured as a child
given the decades that you've spent in
prison and on death row
has your life been worth it
that's a good question i'm glad that my
mother gave me a chance
i'm glad she gave me a chance
jarvis master's next step to arguing for
his exoneration is going to take place
in a hearing in federal court on october
27th the state of california's attorney
general's office will have a chance to
then counter
but in response to our request for an
interview the state wrote that it
refused to answer our questions i know
oprah's been talking about this story
for years i still don't understand why
he is on death row still well you it's
fascinating gail in that he's the guy
who's on death row but he was never
accused of actually committing the
murder exactly and the people who
actually were convicted of committing
the crime are not on death row exactly
that for starters is like wait what
right
it's very strange and it's a reminder
that you always talk about guilty
without a shadow of doubt i mean the
shadow over the criminal justice system
in general is pretty large at this point
and it's troubling look and he's been
trying he's got a powerhouse defense
team now they're going to go to the
federal court system and basically say
the state aired and at the end of the
day if the federal court system decides
that his constitutional rights were
violated jarvis masters has already
served his sentence for armed robbery so
if his conviction is thrown out he
essentially is a free man could be
released wow that's let's see what
happens no one wants criminals to go
free but at the same time you don't want
innocent people to be serving beyond
what they should all right david thank
you very much that's a great piece and a
great selection for the new oprah book
club pick